PACK TO THE POIN
TWO STRAIGHT FOR MONTREAL.
JOSHUA PINS
BYRON BUMPED AND PUSH
MONTREAL AND THE BLUES MAKING
CHANGES NOW.
GAME, THE AVERAGE THIS SEASON.
>> AND IF YOU LOOK AGAINST
PETRY, PIS AND
HANGS ON FOR T T
>> A MINUTE LEFT FOR BORTUZZO.
IS PETRY, BACK BEHIND THE GOAL
THAT IT'S GOING TO GET IT BEHIND
THE NET AS PETRY THROWS IT
AROUND.
>> JOSHUA TRIES TO CENTRE AND A
BIG SAVE GOING IT ON THE LINE.
LEHKONEN AND
>> ARMIA HAS BEEN BETTERE MOVIN
WAS FLYING.OUND.
THE CANADIENS RIGHT AWAY. NOT
WON SINCE JANUARY THE 8TH.RETRE.
>> Sergio: I THINK THE
>> Sergio: THE CANADIENS GET
CAUGHT ON A 3-2 AND MONTEMBEAULT
MAKES THE SAVE ANDND THE CANADI
CHANGING IN THIS 1-1 GAME. OFF
AND DO VERY WELL ON THE REPLAY.E
FACE OFF,
DROP
AS THE GOAL AND
BACKHANDED UP OFF
THOMAS BACK AND TARASENKO BOTH
TEAMS TRY TO GET IT LOOSE. AND S
HIS HEAD DOWN. GAME AND FINALLY
IT
SUZUKI IN A CROWD OF SKATES,
HOFFMAN, WIDEMAN, TENOURTH GOAL.
>> Sergio: THEY DESERVED IT. FA
START C